[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down more Deadpool 3 updates in
case you missed our last video we
dropped that just before the new images
released online showing Hugh Jackman in
his classic yellow costume as we said in
the video the sleeves would still be on
the suit which is now being confirmed by
that new look huge it out so can we get
some toast for calling that and we have
a number of new reports that we need to
go over we also have some footage from
the search showing Wolverine vs Deadpool
and many button spies and my uncle died
retrieving this anyway heavy spoilers
ahead so if you don't want to know then
I highly suggest that you turn off now
we will be discussing some of the leaks
as well so yeah best to stay clear if
you don't want anything potentially
ruined without the way a huge thank you
for clicking the video I'm your host
Paul now let's get into Deadpool 3. so
throughout the week we saw clips of both
Deadpool and Wolverine walking through a
Dusty desert before things broke out
into a fight it looked like it was gonna
be a big battle and I actually have a
couple of theories about what's going on
here now going off the leaks we know
that the TVA will play a big part in the
movie and that elements of this will act
similar to the Loki show Deadpool will
be brought in by the TVA for messing
around with time travel and the device
cable left him will then be confiscated
unfortunately we know that Josh Brolin
won't be returning his cable and it's
been said that we'll be told he's been
returned to his Universe this will be by
Emma Curran's character who according to
the leaks will be playing a TBA judge
he'll then apparently be tasked with
helping the agency out and this will be
similar to how Loki joined them in the
series now his mission if he chooses to
accept it is basically going to be to
kill the fox universe and we have a
number of leaks about what this entails
when over them all in our last video so
if you want to know all the ins and outs
and head over there but I don't just
want to retread old ground instead what
I'm going to do is talk about some of
the other things I've heard since then
touch on some other elements and yeah
just go over what we kind of know so far
now according to the leaks Deadpool will
be tasked with taking out a rogue
timeline which we'll learn is actually
the a38 we'll discover that when Wonder
died in the Multiverse of Madness had a
Consciousness travel to the closest
possible universe and from here she
inhabited the the body that she'd been
puppeting zying was such a traumatic
thing for her that it caused to the lash
out and she destroyed a major part of
this universe's reality along with a lot
of people Elizabeth Olsen's been giving
lots and lots of interviews recently and
she recently gave a hint that she'd be
back for the film which adds a bit of
weight to these leaks now according to
them Magneto stepped in and seized power
and he rules over the planet along with
his band of mutants if you've ever read
House of M then you'll instantly
recognize this aesthetic and the power
bounces shifted between Homo Sapien and
Homo Superior humanity is now dying out
and the mutants rule overall this will
give them the chance to have Wonder
actually being Magneto's daughter and
this version of her may be the main one
that they bring into the MCU from what
I've been told this stuff will be
streamlined after Secret Wars with these
two universes them being combined that's
a similar thing to what happened with
the 616 and the Ultimate Universe and
characters from both ended up in the
universe together after that book this
included Miles Morales and if they ever
do a version of him this could be a way
that they bring him into it now her
coming across wouldn't cancel out the
Scarlet which is death in Multiverse of
Madness and it could be like a more
aware a version of her still around
apparently this all comes in the wake of
the attack on the Illuminati but beyond
that it's also changed things throughout
time if you've seen the flash then
you'll know they did a similar thing in
that and it's also somewhat reverted
elements of the past Wonder's Powers
especially in House of M it reroute all
the past as well and potentially her
coming in has just changed all of
reality now the attack on the Golden
Gate Bridge in X-Men the Last Stand
played out differently with Magneto
being the one who ended up winning the
day so this entire timeline is now
completely and they're gonna have
to stop everything from going off course
so the set pieces that we're seeing seem
to me like they're coming in the middle
of the movie after the point where
Wolverine and Deadpool have then teamed
up however they find themselves in the
void which is something that we also
encountered during Loki episode 5. going
off the photos there's lots of crashed
ships boats Ryan Aries career and things
that have been destroyed by the Marvel
Universe I'm guessing that the two
Heroes will be dumped down here for the
second act and they'll walk through the
vast desert of it before Wolverine just
gets frustrated looks like he's losing
his temper he's just taking it out on
Deadpool and as you know you know he's
got he's got that healing Factor too man
will probably smash him like it's a like
button and it looks like it's gonna
break out into a massive fight and that
takes us into the 20th Century Fox logo
which is gonna be a big set piece where
the action takes place at obviously
Disney acquired the studio and this is
how the characters from the fox
franchises are able to now come over I'm
guessing this is sort of going to be
played like a joke on how Disney handled
their movies and I think we'll get
something about how they bought them and
then left them in the Wasteland now it's
possible this could also plain as some
of the rumors that we've heard which is
that a version of the actor Hugh Jackman
will be playing Wolverine from what's
been leaked we're gonna be getting
several versions of Wolverine in the
film and this includes ones from across
different Marvel properties and the
Deadpool movies they actually talked
about how Hugh Jackman was a real person
and Deadpool even used his face as a
mask from a magazine cover at this
Deadpool 2 ended with him shooting Ryan
Reynolds and we may see Universe where
we encounter both the actors if you cast
your mind back to the first teaser then
you'll remember it had both Ryan and
Hugh announcing the film in real life
and I actually think this could end up
being something similar to what happens
in the film it could both appear as
themselves and this set in the house I'm
guessing it might not be there it might
be the real house but I'm guessing it's
not and this could be a place where big
action scene goes down like I said I
think the main version will probably be
the Wolverine like a real Wolverine and
this is just gonna be a funny little
meta joke that they do at one point in
the film either way Hughes suit could
also indicate what they're doing in the
future or rather the past of the MCU as
we know an X-Men 97 Series has been
announced and this will follow the same
aesthetic as the 90s cartoon it's been
said to be a Marvel Studios project and
there's one can assume that it's indeed
Canon however as far as the Marvel
timeline goes we we've already passed
that yeah and it would have been around
the time that Fury was asking his mates
if they'd ever alien or not not
saying I would may but yeah let me know
in the comments below like like there
are there are some hot aliens to be fair
like I'm just asking for a mate
obviously but like if you've seen
species and stuff you'll know there are
there are some hot aliens and that one
in the the shower in secret Invasion
like she was all right as well now
moving on now because of the air already
being covered it is possible at X-Men 19
7 could actually be a prequel to The a3a
X-Men when we look at Professor X in the
Multiverse of madness he of course
appeared in the classic cartoon chair
and we even had notes from the score
used
foreign
so I think that this is all connected
and that it might use the series as a
way to let us know what the back story
is as speaking of the Illuminati there's
also been rumors that we'll be getting
new members on the team Wanda of course
turns Sue storm into a single mother and
she split Hayley Apple in half like my
dreams after watching Mission Impossible
black Bolt's dead and so is Professor X
though there are rumors that Lashana
Lynch could be back as Captain Marvel
Now side tangent into what the rumored
post credits scene for the Marvels is so
if you don't want to know then turn off
now you still here okay cool so there
are rumors that the Marvels will play
into the film too the trailer for that
opens with Photon investigating
something in space and according to the
leaks this will actually be an incursion
the movie's meant to end with her going
through the incursion barrier and and
it's from this point that you'll end up
in the a38 this is where we'll discover
her mother's actually alive and though
she was crushed by that statue it didn't
actually kill her I take all that with a
pinch of salt but for the moment that's
what's been said to be in the movie
actually have it three times about
something that could be happening in it
which links into an exclusive exclusive
exclusive that we did last year so you
might remember that it got leaked Daniel
Craig was supposed to be in the movie
and a lot of places reported that he was
originally playing Reed Richards I came
out and said I'd actually heard he was
playing ball of the Brave and this has
somewhat being confirmed in interviews
with the actor during the promotion of
Glass Onion he did get asked about it
and made it pretty clear that he had
been a part of it I'm not sure how
you're going to do with this next one
okay have you ever heard of the
character balder of the Brave
no there was a report Daniel that you
were going to be in Dr Strange I believe
it wasn't it
don't you hide behind that mug Daniel
Craig
I don't know what you're talking about
didn't light out and I would say but I
mean the guy is a good actor yeah but he
looking at that he's not a good actor
you know what I mean now the reason he
couldn't do it was because of kovid but
there is the possibility that they could
now bring him back I'd love to see that
with it almost happening the first time
and it would be such a cool Cameo to
have pop-up in the film anyway beyond
that we also have some more cameos that
have been announced since we dropped the
other video last week this includes
Jennifer Garner who'll be showing up as
Electra in part of the Daredevil
Universe this builds off the back of the
Ben Affleck cameo in which he'll be
returning as none other than Daredevil
these characters were also owned by Fox
so I'm guessing that they'll be
incorporated into the logo thing that we
have going on that Daniel rbk has also
been putting out updates on the film and
he was the one who broke the news that
Owen Wilson would be in it I'm pretty
sure he also confirmed that Ms minutes
was returning too and definitely check
out his patreon if you want up to date
Scoops now on Wednesday he put out a
post talking about where they filmed the
scene with the Minutemen and this
involved them chasing Deadpool and
Wolverine through a forest in case you
don't know they're basically TVA
soldiers and rpks describe them as being
similar to Stormtroopers now I know
people have wondered whether we're going
to be getting a sleeveless Wolverine or
not but I can imagine they might do it
in some form or another as for the
outside shots I can see why they've done
this with the sleeves as Hughes made
several posts in the past about how he's
susceptible to skin cancer so they might
have done this just for safety reasons
and they could say this stuff for indoor
shots or who knows even CGI it out it
can be done yeah we're getting a lot of
complaints about CGI but when when they
do it right mate you don't even notice
it now the deleted scene from The
Wolverine originally showed him getting
a costume like this though it has to be
said that it had some slight differences
I am over the moon that were getting it
though and if you told me 10 years ago
we'd have a comic book accurate
Wolverine appearing in the MCU who's
gonna be played by Hugh Jackman
don't speak
it was a time where there was talks
every cast with other actors but I think
he's always going to be the person
people love the most when it comes to
the film so yeah lots of things going on
this week and I'm guessing that we've
had so many trailers and stuff drop
because of the SAG strike seems like
they wanted to get as much out there
before things shut down which is why
we've had this completely crazy amount
of content dropping I'm gonna try and
cover what I can you know some of it
will be old news by now but yeah let me
know your thoughts Below in the comment
section or on everything that's going on
please drop a like as well and if you
want to support the channel as a member
of this spoiler Society then we'd really
appreciate it if you click the join
button you'll get early access to videos
every week and it goes such a long way
to helping us out we also have our merch
store our at shop zeroedition.com which
sells lots of nerdy inspired t-shirts at
some more you just launched a secret
Invasion slash Pulp Fiction inspired
t-shirt so you want to head over there
and help us out then the links in the
description now if you want something
else to watch we've got a video on
screen right now going over the latest
episode of secret Invasion please head
over there after this if not then I
don't know why you're still here yeah
thanks for sticking through the video
I've been Paul I'll see you next time
you take care peace